françois hollande à besançon autrefois
on aurait dit un président en terre
socialiste
oui mais voilà tout a changé premier
selphy les barons socialistes sont là
sauf un le maire de besançon rallier à
emmanuel macron n'a pas fait le
déplacement
depuis plusieurs années maire il a été
élu avec l'étiquette socialiste donc
c'est une ville qui reste de gauche prg
a été bradé des mobilités d'hésitation
et des évolutions mais la population
c'est ça qui compte
elle a des convictions progressiste la
malice de l'ex-président n'a échappé à
personne sans rancune donc première
dédicace devant une trentaine de
militants le dernier carré ce qui n'ont
pas cédé aux sirènes jupitérienne grosse
loose tout le monde et puis qui
finissent par faire mais l'odeur bout
d'un certain temps
françois hollande at il encore un rôle à
jouer
si l'on en croit le nombre de lecteurs
qui l'attendait dans cette librairie
plus de 300 tout est possible génial
rouge qu'on vit actuellement
ça va trop vite c'est pas ça correspond
pas moi je pense à
et il ya des choses qui qui commence à
payer maintenant qu'ils ont été mises en
place durant son quinquennat
un parrain 2 minutes par personne c'est
le tarif
l'ex président prend le temps d'échanger
et de placer ses idées service après
vente de ce mandat
oui peut-être n'at-il pas été fait par
d'autres donc je le fais moi-même parce
que c'est une conception d'abord de la
présidence de la république pour sept
jours humaine c'est aussi des avancées
sociales ce soit un peu perdu c'est la
justice fiscale
elle a été là aussi occulté et donc on
peut comme chaque fois à la fois exprimé
des regrets mais aussi faire la
différence
soixante dix mille exemplaires déjà
vendus l'ouvragé de françois hollande a
pris le pouvoir dans les librairies
partout où il passe les dédicaces se
poursuivre tard dans la nuit
l'ex-président serait-il devenu le plus
un tranquille des socialistes